what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so picking up with the second part
of the secret origin of Tony Stark
really starts origin the recorder and
and what's really what's really going on
with the motivations of recorder four
five one and what we end up finding out
here is that following the birth of Tony
Stark uh they effectively call it a day
like the recorders just kind of like
okay he takes off and that's really yeah
because his jobs done and it's really
kind of cool here because with
everything that's happened the question
of Howard and Maria Stark is what do we
do now it's what a kind of cool because
I feel like that's the the question
almost every parent asks you know I
think that's one of the things that
makes you know parenting parenting
pretty exciting well the whole idea here
at least from what a recorder 451 tells
Tony Stark is that he was engineered for
a particular purpose and the purpose was
to basically pilot something called the
god killer armor now the god killer
armor is a really really cool concept
because it's basically like anti
celestial tech but the reason why is
because of the fact you remember record
for 51 looked around and basically said
people are gonna become jealous of the
earth are gonna become concerned about
the earth but because of all the
inhabitants because the super-powered
beings that exist here the earth could
one day become a beacon of peace in the
universe now we know that just by way of
like Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
that Avengers world will be formed
Avengers world will happen but we're
given this cool bit of history about the
Marvel Universe now something else is
going on and in fact will actually cover
this in our story about The Ultimates
when we viciously get to a retcon of the
universe all Ultimates is basically
retelling this entire origin story um
when it comes to the whole the whole
concept of the god killer armor back in
the early days of the universe's
existence that is to say this version of
the Marvel Universe which I think is the
seventh iteration of the universe a war
broke out between the Celestials and the
aspirins
but the aspirins and the Celestials are
both vying for dominance of the universe
now what the motivation of the aspirins
were again we don't know there are very
emag Matic race of people all we knew is
that the Celestials basically procreate
by taking control of a planet
impregnating the planet with the
energies of a celestial and then when
that celestial emerges the plan is
destroyed and then there's one more
celestial in the cosmos the idea was
that before the aspirants to basically
stop that from happening and to defeat
the Celestials but during the war
between the aspirants and the Celestials
themselves the aspirins had developed
the god-killer armor that stands 25,000
feet tall and this
odd killer armour served the purpose of
basically destroying Celestials and the
war was massive it was a universe wide
war now what we learned in Ultimates is
that this conflict is simply the seventh
time has happened that back in the
beginning of all things when the very
first universe came into existence that
universe was basically called the
firmament and that universe created
aspirants and it created Celestials both
of these beings were designed to
basically view the view the first
firmament as being you know kind of like
a an all-encompassing entity that is to
say they basically worshipped it the
problem is that some of these beings
namely the Celestials began to operate
with autonomy which is to say they
basically broke away from the influence
of the first firmament and became their
own beings and so because of this the
war between the Celestials and they and
the aspirants was actually a war between
those who are loyal to the first
firmament and those who were not and so
because of this the Celestials basically
won the first firmament was pushed to
the brink of all existence and the cycle
repeated itself each time the universe
took form so each time the universe
collapsed and a new ohm was born the
entire cycle repeated all over again the
exception to this is that the first
firmament existed outside of all space
and time and outside of the main
universe itself and just watched the
multiverse collapse and be reborn six or
seven times leading up to the formation
of the all-new all-different marvel
universe following the events of secret
Wars and so of course what we find out
is that with tony stark being here with
record of 451 still maintaining control
of his suit of armour what happened is
that when recorder 451 went to the
planet vol d led Tony Stark there and
then stole the heart of the baldy the
reason for that is because of the fact
that the heart was needed to power the
god-killer armor and the idea here is
that record 451 essentially engineer
Tony Stark's so that he and he alone
could pilot the god killer armor station
it on planet earth and become
essentially a warning to anybody who
shows up on earth that there would be
massive ramifications because you got to
thank anybody who showed up on earth
with the intention of attacking it would
be obliterated by the god killer armor
just because the amount of power that it
possesses I mean it's just ridiculous of
course in the middle of all this were
met by the arrival of death's head and
the reason why is because of the fact
that where the character of deaths head
it was recorder 451 trying to wrap up
all loose
death's-head is for all intents and
purposes the best bounty hunter in the
entire Marvel Universe and because of
this with him being as capable as he is
the recorder basically put a bounty on
his head and so this really kind of
shows us the arrogance and the hubris of
the recorder to basically try to
eliminate the greatest bounty hunter in
the in the universe by sending other
bounty hunters after him and so again
what this does is because of the fact
that death's-head is just a giant
machine the recorder hacks into him and
essentially shuts him down you know
really just kind of makes him into his
own personal slave and so again the
commands that have been given to these
individuals that the recorder hacks into
namely the suit of Iron Man and death's
head is do not allow me to be harmed do
not harm me and carry out my orders now
they're given free will to do anything
they want to but if Tony Stark tried to
kill record a 4 or 5 1 this suit
wouldn't let him if death's-head tried
to kill record or 4 or 5 1 his body
wouldn't let him but he still maintains
his own mind he still maintains his own
intelligence and his own thoughts and
desires and even free speech he just
can't kill record a 4-5-1 and has to
follow all of his orders and so because
of this Tony Stark's required to think
fast now because of the fact that the
suit itself responds to Tony Stark as
much as it responds to Pepper Potts is
really kind of like a like a redundant
system if the Pepper AI essentially
becomes corrupted Tony Stark can
basically purge it and then operate the
suit on his own and that's exactly what
he does of course the pepper AI pretty
much kind of goes with this idea as well
because it's the only way to save what
it is it's happening but Stark
essentially shuts down the suit and then
just runs and that's it so at this point
he's really just kind of stuck on his
feet but the funny thing about this is
that when deaths head is shown up and it
basically fought on behalf of Tony Stark
even for only a moment he made reference
to the fact that Tony Stark's own
weapons systems had followed him there
now the reason why was because with the
pepper AI basically taken over by
reporter 4 or 5 1 the AI was still able
to function and use all of its normal
resources and so what it basically did
is it realized if reporter 4-5-1 hacked
into me then I can basically recall all
the armors of Tony Stark when it doesn't
realize what's going on and Tony Stark
and basically just jury rigged the armor
so that they can work without having to
worry about you know record a 4-5-1
hacking into them and that's exactly
what he does
he basically began routing all these
different suits of armor to essentially
wire them all together as a dummy system
so recorder for 5
one can use them but the fact remains
that with regards to death's-head
because it's essentially acting to try
to destroy record a 4-5-1 it essentially
acts around the parameters that it
basically just kind of takes four or
five one and just dives off the side of
you know one of the ledges hoping that
it'll destroy recorder four or five one
at the same time because when they hit
the bottom of the god killer armor
they'll have been traveling almost five
miles because of how tall it is of
course you know a record of four 5:1
says unhand me and that's that that's
the end of deaths head but again what
this does is it shows us the
intelligence and the ingenuity of Tony
Stark but it's also this idea that not
everything is what it seems and the
reason why is because Karen Gillan is
hinting at the idea that either
something went wrong with the plan of
recorder 451 or Tony Stark is not the
child of Howard and Maria and the reason
why is because of the fact that the
child of Howard Maria was programmed to
be able to access indigent to pilot the
god-killer armor when recorder four or
five one sends the god killer armor
careening into a planet hoping that Tony
Stark will seize control his pilot merge
with the armor and then deterred away
from the planet itself Stark tries it
and can't control the suit he cannot
control the ship and so because of this
the indication here from Karen Gillan is
a Tony Stark is not the biological child
of Howard and Maria now this is really
interesting because when this first drop
it was the talk of the town Tony Stark
is not the child of how in Moorea that's
crazy but the fact remains here that
with Tony Stark
unable to pilot the suit of armor
ultimately it ends up destroying the
planet now again this is where the the
whole views and the whole perspectives
begin to shift and the reason why is
because of the fact that from the
perspective of a record of 4-5-1 Tony
Stark did not stop the god killer armor
from crashing into the planet because he
chose not to not because he couldn't and
so again this is really kind of
interesting because it makes Recorder
4-5-1 very human in the sense it is he's
just kind of ignoring facts in place of
what he believes to be true because in
truth he doesn't know what's going on it
also shows us how durable and how strong
the recorders are I mean they're nyan
Stockwell just in terms of their
physical structure in terms of the
durability now there's all different
kinds of things that he can do but
ultimately alongside the assistance of
pepper the hacking system of recorder
4-5-1 is destroyed which in turn frees
her from his control and religious
sets the stage for the recorder system
to be almost completely obliterated now
before this happens Tony Stark actually
grabs the recorder drags him over to one
of the interface devices and forces the
recorder to bear witness to the fact
that Tony Stark cannot control it like
you couldn't tell him the truth you had
to make him see the truth with the
recorder basically realizing that the
Tony Stark is not the child of Howard
and Maria the question becomes then who
is who is the child of Howard and Maria
now at this point for the recorder it
doesn't matter I mean is his life is
basically done I mean it's really just
kind of over and so because of the fact
that he says look I acted in what I
thought was the best interest only for
me to find out that I basically screwed
up my purpose is no it essentially just
kind of deletes itself and so because of
that Tony Stark really has no way out I
mean the doors are sealed sure the
god-killer armor is sent away from the
planet Earth but it's also told by the
recorder to begin the process of jumping
to another dimension to jump to another
reality and it'll take Tony Stark with
it it starts not able to get out and so
again building on this intelligence of
Tony Stark of course he ends up grabbing
the recorder and then hooking up it's
hacking system and breaking himself free
that's really it just kind of gets him
out as fast as he possibly can and then
they basically just bail out but
something else that I also want you to
hope I want you to notice here is the
idea of a Dyson Sphere when the
god-killer armor was first introduced as
part of this story it was basically
hidden away from all things in existence
inside of a Dyson Sphere of course the
Dyson Sphere serving the purpose or
serving multiple purposes of being able
to like absorb solar energy you know
built around a star that kind of thing
but it was designed for the purpose of
keeping the god-killer
armor hidden the reason why this matters
is because this is yet another instance
when Hickman will reach into existing
stories from the IO Man comics and the
Captain America comics and so on and
roll them over into incursions and
everything when the Infinity Gauntlet
when the gems shattered and they weren't
able to use a gauntlet anymore Tony
Stark decided to build a Dyson Sphere
around the Sun and then channeled the
energies of the Sun to destroy in
cursing planets so again it was really
kind of a cool idea in terms of how it
all just kind of reaches together and
how it all kind of comes back in but
what we end up having here is Tony Stark
arriving back on earth only to find out
that where he had basically taken off
before his birthday she essentially just
kind of held his birthday celebration
off until he got back and then it's the
Avengers and everything but the
important thing here is that Tony Stark
begins to remember what it was that went
on with regards to recorder four or five
the idea that the programmed child of
Howard and Maria's Stark was made for
the purpose of being able to access the
god-killer Armour the fact that Tony
Stark wasn't able to do that meant that
he was not the biological child of
Howard a Maria Stark now the reason why
he comes to this conclusion is because
of the fact that recorders are robots
they're not designed to be human they're
not designed to make mistakes in this
instance with everything that it was
that recorder four or five one had done
there was no reason to indicate that it
was wrong about the idea that only
Howard and Maria's child should be able
to access the god-killer armor and so
after going through all this
documentation and going through all this
different paperwork Tony Stark comes to
the only logical conclusion that he can
that Howard a Maria Stark do have a
child and that child is not him and so
what we do is we jump back to the
initial scenario when a reporter four or
five one appeared to Howard Emery astark
and offer the option of allowing them to
have a child but stating that there
would be some genetic modifications that
would be made to it and in this
discussion between the two of them they
effectively just wrote notes to one
another asking the question can it be
trusted do you believe that it has our
best interest in hearts and so again it
really showed the idea that from the
very beginning Howard and Maria Stark
did not trust recorder 4-5-1 now
ultimately they ended up going through
with it the change to the plan came by
way of Howard Stark himself and again
this shows us just how smart he is and
so what we end up finding out here is
that when Maria Stark was impregnated
with a child and then recorder four or
five one began the process of
genetically modifying that child Howard
began to go through with all the notes
that he was given by recorder four or
five one and began meddling around and
investigating in terms of what was
happening and found a hidden line of
code that was basically designed for the
purpose of killing the child of how and
Maria Stark when it was around thirty
when it was in his 30s maybe close to 40
and so it was basically a suicide gene
now we know by virtue of reading the
story the gene was created by a recorder
451 so that it would be able to grab the
child of Howard Maria stark whisk it off
to the low to the god-killer armor make
it part of the god-killer armor
presumably infusing its mind with the
armor itself making it a pilot and then
his physical body would just shut down
so there would be nothing left but the
mind stuck inside the god-killer armor
what Howard did is he basically created
a serum
sorts that would disrupt this gene now
the crazy thing about this is he does
not tell his wife he does not tell Maria
stark about what's going on but it's not
because he doesn't trust her he does it
because of the fact that a recorder
4-5-1 kept extremely close tabs on Maria
stark because of the fact that the
future of all the recorders plans hinged
on this child being born happy and
healthy and so what is up happening here
is that when the baby's born
it shows some struggling it shows some
we zenus and it's effectively born with
cellular degeneration and this is when
Howard Stark says I found a weird kind
of scenario a weird line of code inside
this kid's genes I try to find a way to
neutralize it and instead I basically
incapacitated our child their mind will
stay intact but they'll never be able to
use their physical body the other half
of this is that every quarter 4-5-1 ever
found out about this it would likely
kill Howard and Maria Stark and start
over again with somebody else presumably
somebody a little more naive that can't
quite investigate on the same level that
Howard Stark did and so in order to
maintain their position in terms of
keeping everything under wraps what they
ended up doing is they took their
biological child are no Stark they put
him in their own little Hospice of sorts
and then in turn they adopted Tony Stark
to keep their cover to make it look like
everything was going along as planned
and so the implication here is that Tony
Stark is just as smart as he is because
he's just that damn smart because he's
just that intelligent but putting two
and two together for the first time in
his life he encounters his brother Arno
Stark and this is so cool because
Arnold's first first you know really
statement to him is just so you know I
would have worked it out like a decade
ago and so for the most part they get on
with a pretty good start now of course a
lot of this seems to be because of the
fact that Arno is quite aware that Tony
Stark was never told about what was
going on so he's coming into this
completely blind stark never knew about
what was happening and so the result of
this is that with these two brothers
being extremely intelligent then the
question becomes if this is what Tony
Stark was able to do in isolation and he
does not seem to have the intelligence
that his brother has in terms of being
so capable what in the world could they
possibly do together and so what this
does is this sets the stage for the next
story by Karen Gillan called iron
metropolitan anyway
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I'll catch you all later
peace
[Music]